Well done.
You've made it through to the end,
and you've learned a lot about
prototyping and user reasearch.
Now that you've learned how to iterate,
how to bring on team members and
how to share your project, you're
ready to do the work on your own app.
Remember that this work can be done many
times over to get yourself to a great
finished product, and that you should
expect to throw out many early versions
to find one that resonates
with your users.
Once you've done this work, you'll
still need to actually build your app.
But that part of it will go way more
smoothly with this prep work complete.
By listening to users before
you build the app itself,
you can be sure you're creating
a great experience for them.
Now get out there and start prototyping.